in this video we're going to build on
our understanding of mendelian genetics
and punnett squares
by starting to think about two different
genes so we're going back to the pea
plant and we're going to think about the
gene for p
color and the gene for p shape
so let's say that in the parental
generation
you have one parent that is homozygous
dominant for
both of these genes so their genotype
is capital y capital y and
capital r capital r so their phenotype
for sure is going to be yellow round and
we also see the genotype we see
which alleles it has now let's say that
that is crossed with a homozygous
recessive parent so in this case it's
going to
be green colored peas it's
counterintuitive to write green with the
y
a lowercase y and the color yellow but
the lowercase y represents green
and also these are wrinkled green peas
so i will write that with the lowercase
r here
and so the phenotype here is going to be
green
and wrinkled for sure now what's going
to happen when they cross
what does the f1 generation look like
well we know from mendel's law
of segregation for each of these genes
that when a gamete is created it
randomly gets one
copy of each of these genes so for this
first one it's going to randomly get
one of these capital y's so it's going
to get a capital y
for sure from this first parent and it's
also going to randomly get one of these
capital r's
so it's going to get a capital r for
sure from that first parent
and then by the same logic it's going to
randomly get one of these two lowercase
y's
so it's going to get a lowercase y for
sure
and it's going to randomly get one of
these two lowercase r's so it's going to
get a lowercase r for sure
so this is the genotype for all of the
f1
generation this is often known as a
dihybrid
it is heterozygous in both genes
now what's the phenotype here well we
know yellow is dominant and we know
round is dominant so if we looked at
these plants right over here their peas
would still be yellow round
just like this homozygous parent over
here now what's interesting is when you
do what's known as a
dihybrid cross when you cross one of
this
f1 generation with itself or with each
other
and to do that i'm going to create a
four by four
punnett square here and so one parent
here
is going to be hybrid in or heterozygous
in the color gene and also heterozygous
in the shape gene and that's going to be
true of the other parent as well
heterozygous or hybrid in the color gene
and also heterozygous in the shape gene
and so that's why this is called a
dihybrid cross you're crossing things
that are hybrid in two different genes
now we've already talked about the law
of segregation
though gamete is randomly going to get
one copy of each gene
now mendel also has the law of
independent assortment
which tells us the alleles of different
genes segregate independently
so for this first parent here whether it
contributes a
capital y or lowercase y is independent
of whether it contributes a capital r or
a lowercase r
now there is a little bit of an asterisk
a little caveat on there
we now know that genes sit on
chromosomes one chromosome will have
many genes on it
and this law of independent assortment
only applies to genes
that are actually sitting on different
chromosomes if they sit on the same
chromosome
they generally are not going to assort
independently
but let's just assume the law of
independent assortment because this is
true for most
genes so this first parent can
contribute
a capital y out of this first gene
and a capital r out of the second gene
or they could contribute the lowercase
copy of the first gene
and the capital r copy
of the second gene this capital r the
round allele of the second gene
and we could go through every
combination here it could also
contribute
the yellow allele and
the wrinkled allele or it could
contribute
the green allele
and the wrinkled allele as well
and the same would be true for this
other dihybrid this other
parent right over here so let me just
write that down they could contribute
capital y in two of the scenarios they
could contribute a lowercase y
or the green allele in two of the
scenarios and they could contribute
a capital r in two of the scenarios a
round allele
or lowercase r in two of the scenarios a
wrinkled allele
so you have all of the different
combinations that each of them can
contribute and you can once again
whether you get the yellow or the green
is independent of whether you get the
round or the wrinkled
so these are all equally probable right
over here
when the two gametes from these two
parents merge we can then look at what
the genotype of the offspring is going
to be really the genotype of the f2
generation because we're crossing
two members of the f1 generation so i
encourage you to pause this video and
fill in this grid
see if you can figure out the different
genotypes that will result
all right now let's do this together so
this scenario right over here you're
getting a capital y
from both parents and you're getting a
capital r
from both parents this scenario over
here you're getting a capital y
from this parent lowercase y from that
parent
and then you're getting a capital r from
both
this scenario over here capital y from
both parents
capital y capital y and you're getting a
capital r
from the this parent and a lowercase r
from that parent and then this scenario
over here you're getting a capital y
allele from this parent and lowercase y
from that parent
and you're getting a capital r from this
parent and a lowercase r
from that parent and now i'm just going
to speed up the video
and just fill in the rest of these using
the same logic
all right now that we've filled out this
punnett square let's think about the
different phenotypes
how many of these plants are going to
produce yellow round peas pause the
video and think about it
well it's yellow and round it has to
have
at least one capital y and one capital r
so that one's going to be yellow and
round
this is going to be yellow and round
this is going to be yellow and round
that's yellow and round as well this is
yellow and round
that's yellow and round this is yellow
and round
and that one is yellow and round and
then
last but not least i think this is the
last one that is both
yellow and round and actually let me
make a little color code here
yellow yellow plus round and here we're
talking about the phenotype you can see
we have different genotypes here
but because both yellow and round are
dominant as long as you have at least
one y
and one r you're going to have a yellow
plus round
phenotype over here so you have one two
three four five six
seven eight nine and i will say there's
nine
of these over here now how many of these
are going to be
yellow plus wrinkled
pause the video and think about that
that phenotype
so yellow and wrinkled you're going to
have to have a capital y
and two lowercase r's in order to be
wrinkled
so you have at least one capital y and
two lowercase r's at least one capital y
and two lowercase r's let's see at least
one capital y
and two lowercase r's it looks like you
have exactly three of them
that phenotype and then what about the
other way around
what if we are looking for and i'll do
it in this green color
green green
plus round how many of them exhibit that
phone phenotype
well to be green and round you have to
have two lowercase ys
and you have to have at least one
capital r so
this would be green and round this would
be
green and round and then this would be
green and round as well so you have
three of those
and then how many of them are going to
be both green and wrinkled
well i think you see that one scenario
over here that is both green and
wrinkled having that
homozygous recessive phenotype and so if
you were to do this many times you'd
expect the ratios between these various
phenotypes
to be nine to three to three to one
and when mendel and many other people
since mendel have done these types of
experiments they have seen that
statistically
this is what you see in that f2
generation now you're unlikely to get
exactly a nine to three to three to one
ratio it's all probabilistic
every one of these 16 scenarios are
equally likely
so you would expect this 9 to 3 to 3 to
1 ratio
but you're not always going to get that
exact ratio you'll probably get
something close to it